[Music]
in YouTube drama news submitted by tips
hair it's a Peru now it's kind of green
though it's kind of green I mean he's
fading teal teal teal yeah dirty teal
boys Oh youtuber mr. beast response to
accusations of allegedly bullying his
former editor Eddie so there's no way
he's a saint
I've seen him get thousands of dollars
away the people I never met mr.
fantastic but I'm gonna I'm protecting
him I am not sarcastic no idea finally
someone witnesses you're losin us let
the right girl thank you even at your
show she's writing this [ __ ] you don't
know her she deserves that she's a
butcher she's a savage she [ __ ] ruins
people's lives
Thank You Mia she's a flame thrower
listen no one appreciates always oh
never it's just a meme I was just in the
middle of trying to say something it's
like when people see other people
throwing up and then they throw up
that's how I am with people crying don't
make me cry girl oh my god don't make me
- should we cry will it get more views
yo let's all cry that I think all of us
vomiting would get more views oh yeah
very smart smart man all right so this
is Steve's favorite youtuber of all time
my favorite might take him for a moment
he's mine I don't know he's mine I
already I brought him up first
he's the mother Teresa of our time I
don't even know who he is yeah please
yeah I don't know I've been telling you
guys all day he's awesome
oh good now I got it Channel yep you
weren't listening oh yeah you guys
weren't here last week never mind
so this is mr. beast Jimmy Jimmy aka mr.
beast okay and then this guy his name is
mark I think mark why does he look like
a black lady going to church on Sunday
which one mr. B's which one's mr. B's
but the banks yeah with the bangs the
bangs and the hair hat you know like I
don't know like that I think you were
anyway so he unpopular opinion but but
the mark looks like you
wants to get bullied which one both look
like James Blunt Oh true other things
met sorry Nana yeah I mean it's not my
opinion but unpopular opinion that I saw
a resume
some people look like they should be
some people look like they should be
bullies what you're saying yeah I've
read that and it's wait yeah yes I got
bullied Ida wasn't the bullier you still
look like you would have taken you're
being bullied out on me and bullied me
and I told you I was a stoner and I was
really cool I was annoying this [ __ ] I
would have tested your limits I'm high
we would have been really good were you
bullied Mia yeah I was fat as [ __ ]
really and Middle Eastern I hadn't fully
lost my accent yet and I was 2001 and in
DC so like the Pentagon got hit and
everything
Oh school was not fun for me Wow
why are you so fat my mom would just
feed me everything and then I got old
enough to know what weed was and it just
made it worse and it tastes so good
Audrey is so good yeah who's your main
go-to meal rice oh wow right really mean
rice is like a very Middle Eastern we
always have rice made in the fridge it's
made like every other day there's always
a rotation and still flavor though no
but there's always something to eat the
rice way and if there isn't you put a
little salt on some Greek yogurt and you
mix that [ __ ] up oh that's not
interesting yeah so we're talking about
mr. beast here okay so what did he do
did he grab the editors but wait can I
just no because Joe sucks at explaining
can you just tell me what mr. beast is
about I know you don't you suck at
listening girl awesome oh I'll take it
because I need to redeem myself we're
gonna fair because I've said this
multiple times mr. B's is awesome
because what he does is he does these
videos where he's like check this out
I'm gonna do $50,000 what the scratchers
with my buddy and then he [ __ ] does
that and he moved on to giving streamers
like $10,000 or what about $400,000 are
you just trying to suck up to him to get
the money no no I really like his
content because but then now it's even
more like next level because well he'll
do is you'll have a whole entire car lot
and you
by that [ __ ] out for hundreds of
thousands of dollars and then kill you
did say that I do about listening
eight dollars six dollars and that was
his name okay was mr. Mesa he's the same
Wow
yeah and he will sell cars for $12 yeah
any pillars you will be dealing with the
customer and you'll be like all right
all right
$10 are you driving a hard bargain I'll
give you 500 ours and oh my god I'm deep
throating the [ __ ] out of his car how
many fingers did he put in ladies
[ __ ] why did he [ __ ] up so the editor
key here is saying growth so mad
initially when he quit who editing for
mr. beasts he came out with the video
saying like oh my god it was so awesome
working there like I loved my job like
they're so good to me and oh I like just
sucking up to mr. beast and the whole
crew okay sounds good so far now out of
nowhere like literally there's no reason
why now he decided to like switch it up
but now he's saying he ended up tweeting
out like first of all I'm not gonna make
a video about this but I hated working
with mr. mr. beast or whatever and then
he also said like here's a tweet after
every editing mistake I made I was made
to feel like an absolute idiot well
maybe because he was even if the content
wasn't real no credit was given
parentheses unless a video I edited got
credit to someone else if we ever leave
the team we shouldn't be we shouldn't be
set up for success after so no credit
will be given ideas would be taken
people would be baited into the team and
I would scream and I would be screamed
at and then told I just misinterpreted
what I heard by his impossible to please
momager why is he such a complaint it
has [ __ ] sounds like a normal job to me
exactly that's how we treat Jeff yeah
you [ __ ] all over Jeff yeah he's taking
it this was a lily we tried to get a
camera on his face right now Jeff is our
manager Jeff is my manager sorry yes
right yeah
so that's what this kid is saying and he
used to shut the [ __ ] up because I wanna
bully him you know what this is what's
wrong with society in America these days
everyone is such a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah no
one has any work ethic they don't know
know who's not a [ __ ] though our fans
because when they're subscribed they're
not a sensitive as [ __ ]
so prove to me you're not a sensitive as
[ __ ] by subscribing because JK news
fans we keep fuc alive and everybody
here are some down ass [ __ ] why
I left BuzzFeed or whatever and it's
like yeah so like they were kind of mean
to me and like one one time they stole
my lunch from my fridge it's always like
basic ass [ __ ] yeah shut up you [ __ ] if
someone applied honestly for a job with
me and if I google their name and I saw
like why I left whatever that's
immediately I'm never gonna hire it yes
I know your little [ __ ]
David so why I love chicken is I'm like
never gonna hire someone being a bad
leader and a bad boss just because they
don't have the leadership skills that
that are you know useful for like
helping people know what they've done
wrong sometimes all you can really say
is that [ __ ] sucks and you suck yep
and you're supposed to take that yeah
and bad about how terrible you were
treated it's a job you [ __ ] well
another thing too is what people need to
do is be like us and not fire people
just keep them trapped until they
[ __ ] become better [ __ ] and
if they do leave you leave on good terms
or you threaten the [ __ ] out of them so
they never say anything bad you ever see
a [ __ ] wildlife JK video never you'll
never see it from our past team members
or anything like that afraid right
they're afraid I'll [ __ ] murder them
and their whole entire family that's
what leadership by the way leadership
that's that's you you're doing it wrong
mr. B's you're too [ __ ] nice to
[ __ ] I said you know he did to this
kid don't ever leave gave my hon $2,000
we gave him $10,000 like - I got a
severance
kind of thing where it's like okay you
know what I like you he got severance
and he's still [ __ ] complaining not
only that but he found him a new job and
he told this guy kid hey that apartment
that I'm paying for your rent and stuff
like feel free to stay there as long as
you want
Oprah oh my god who he might as well
have just sucked his [ __ ] dick ass
severance
what is it okay to bully someone so then
let me tell you some more details it
builds character so right now there's
he's saying so this one example that he
gave talking about how his horrible
experience being an employee there or
like an editor for mr. beast he said
that one time he had to edit all like a
compilation of all the times he ever
gave money out and he wanted it to or he
it was supposed to add up to $500,000
but Matt's saying that it's always like
clickbait it like rounded up amount so
he was just going based off of the
titles mr. Bies is going based off of
the title is adding it up to five
hundred thousand but instead it was
maybe like four hundred and ten dollars
so then he's saying like when he
presented this video to mr. beasts he
was like are you [ __ ] like how could
you not like do it again I keep deleted
the footage or the edit he deleted the N
I made him redo it again and he spent
about like forty hours on the same video
like giving him the same result like I
can't change the numbers I can't make it
add up to five hundred thousand and he
Matt is claiming that mr. Bies was just
so unreasonable
so like insanely mean to him for not
getting the number right and he'll just
like that wasn't a my everyday working
with this see this is always what it is
though the action itself doesn't sound
bad at all but then you say so
unreasonable agree just terrible
horrifying but then I'm like okay but
the actions fine yeah that just tells me
he told you to do something and your
dumb ass had to [ __ ] spend so many
hours doing that one simple job that you
couldn't [ __ ] complete and he's
pissed at you because it's like I could
have anybody else do this [ __ ] you sure
you're [ __ ] [ __ ] eyes can't do it
you shouldn't have to hike man how bad
it is you should just be able to tell us
how bad it isn't in law like oh yeah
that's really yeah if it was mr. B's
came in and [ __ ] suck my [ __ ]
yep that explain that [ __ ] it's just oh
wow you know you already know how I
reason all right it's not 40 hours of
normal work week - can we see this guy
again this is a quote 40 hours on the
same video me getting screamed at
oh no yeah I better get back in this
room with no windows and after so long
away
you [ __ ] editing rooms don't have
windows you idiots Eclair
he said I'm literally gonna start crying
look at this [ __ ] bored we're in a
racing chair look at his [ __ ] gamer
chair too behind them you can see it
dude let me explain some more so he was
saying you know what everyone's saying
that I'm coming out with this
information out to be a cloud chaser
he's like no in reality back then when I
was raving about how awesome it was to
work with him that's when I was touched
oh my god it's like then now I have
nothing to gain I'm actually probably
gonna get blacklisted from the editing
Communion you did got blacklisted here
yeah and then it's just like he's like
so what do i what do I have to gain from
this why would I say all of this it's
just that it's really annoying when
someone that's known as the saint online
like they don't know how they really are
in person is everybody got a dark side
boob you're gonna see him editing
highlight reels for little league hockey
games that's his next job yes p.m. said
whether or not mr. beast is a saint or
not like he's Bo prover who knows right
but I know for a fact that this guy's a
little [ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah so and
that's why people go Jake how come you
guys don't hire any more interns cuz I
don't like little [ __ ] is why and I
don't want to have my team waste their
[ __ ] time training you little [ __ ]
faces cuz you're [ __ ] too [ __ ] damn
sensitive that's why you solve a [ __ ]
you're so angry
[Music]
[Music]